no they're they're they're bonkers
aren't they
they're absolutely mad the targaryens
they're a right old bunch and emotional
they're so emotional and they can't talk
to each other yeah quite a cross family
deep down
i think they need a lot a great deal of
therapy they do
group therapy yeah
yeah
the
realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video well my
friends it looks like entertainment
weekly once again is giving us their
exclusive behind-the-scenes look at
house of the dragon's first season they
released their new article only a few
hours ago which also includes several
new photos as well as their own teaser
video
not only are we getting another great
look at the actors on set but we're also
getting a hell of a lot more information
regarding how the series was made and
how this amazing story will unfold
during that first season for those of
you who want to see everything for
yourself there will be a link down below
i would highly recommend watching their
whole teaser video as well as reading
the new article because as i said
there's a lot of interesting information
to go over now let me show you some of
the interesting things that were said
the headline reads burning down the
house how game of thrones enters a new
age with house of the dragon
now ever since game of thrones ended in
2019 everyone in hollywood seems to want
their own version of a high fantasy
emmy-winning blockbuster series in fact
only a few weeks after house of the
dragon airs its first episode in late
august amazon will follow up with an
even bigger swing at the brass ring with
their new lord of the rings series
george rr martin said he's happy for the
lord of the rings show to succeed but he
wants house of the dragon to do better
if they win six semis and i hope they do
i hope we win seven he said and maybe
the next game of thrones is indeed game
of thrones that is if viewers can get
over the discourse surrounding the
original show for better or worse
everyone had and still has something to
say about how game of thrones series
creators david benioff and db weiss
ended the final season of their
adaptation of george rr martin's novels
the most barbarous critics suggested it
ruined all of game of thrones for them
which actor patty considine who will be
king viserys targaryen on house of the
dragon can't understand even if he
doesn't wholly agree when you live with
something for so many years and watch
those characters on that adventure i
think fans and critics alike start to
write their own endings he said i feel
like a bit of that happened and i bet i
was one of them as well
fans are always going to have something
to say about the way a beloved things
comes to an end add showrunner ryan
condole who co-created house of the
dragon with george rr martin what they
say doesn't really affect the way we
handle this show we have this giant
legacy to carry forward and we want to
do that in the best way that honors what
came before but also doesn't do the
thing that i think a lot of sequels do
here's what you loved wrapped up in a
different way now it's hard to disagree
with him when having these discussions
in front of a man-made set like
dragonstone the ancestral seat of house
targaryen where a boiler embedded
beneath the stage releases smoke up
through the floors around the sharp
black stone to evoke the active volcano
that encases the castle at the same time
it's also hard not to see house of the
dragon as a response in some ways to the
fan feedback
throughout the show's eight seasons the
depiction of game of thrones female
characters became a big discussion among
viewers house of the dragon now has
women more at the forefront with a focus
on rhaenyra targaryen and her childhood
best friend allison hightower the hand
of the king's daughter their
relationship is at the center of a chasm
that threatens to tear westeros apart
for reasons that are already clear to
book readers based on george rr martin's
fire and blood which chronicles the rich
history of house targaryen house of the
dragon goes back hundreds of years
before daenerys and jon snow to a
historical event known as the dance of
the dragons it's at the height of the
targaryen rule in westeros in
considine's king viserys has chosen his
first born rhaenyra as the heir to the
iron throne the lords of westeros swear
fealty to her but when viserys conceives
a son the young aegon in the following
years the once unified house is split in
two over the matter of succession the
conflict framed on the series through
the relationship between rhaenyra and
alicent leads to what is most likely the
bloodiest civil war the country has ever
seen
the events building up to and during the
war spanned decades according to
martin's fire and blood house of the
dragon will unfold linearly over those
decades with millie allcock and emily
carey as rhaenyra and alicent the young
girls before emma darcy and olivia cook
take over the roles as adults ryan
condell says the dance of the dragons
first mentioned in the novels through
ballads sung by bards was always
martin's idea when hbo began debating
what ice and fire story to tell next
there's a saying in westeros every time
a new targaryen is born the gods flip a
coin in the air and the world holds its
breath to see how it will land madness
and greatness are on opposite sides
well there are a lot of targaryens in
house of the dragon and also a lot of
dragons under the rule of king viserys
the country has seen more than 70 years
of peace it's a time of great wealth and
decadence which is one reason why the
iron throne is so decked out before
things come crashing down it's also the
age when most dragons flew the skies of
westeros
just about every targaryen has their own
mount a stark contrast to game of
thrones which saw daenerys as one of the
last remaining targaryens and dragons
virtually extinct i wanted to tell a
story about the height of rome before
the fall and see the targaryen dynasty
at its very apex so that we can
understand a thing that was lost when it
all fell apart ryan condo explains at
the center of the story is rhaenyra whom
the executive producer says is the most
important role in the show in many ways
miguel sapochnick who also directs three
of the first season's episodes agrees
i'm so excited about them being the face
of the show if the gods flip the coin
for the birth of daemon the volatile
brother of viceros and another heir to
the throne smith who is 39 says the coin
is still in motion
it hasn't quite hit the ground yet and
until its final doom we won't find out
what side he's on
daemon is likely the targaryen of the
age most skilled in combat wielding the
famed valyrian steel sword dark sister
one of the ancestral blades of his house
now to understand the heart of daemon
you need only look at his dragon karaxis
or gargantuan winged red steed matt
smith thinks of the beast as a very
grumpy surly sort coraxis is constantly
annoyed but daemon loves that about him
he's like a massive rabid dog in many
ways who only relaxes around daemon says
smith he's almost an untrainable dragon
in many respects one could say the same
thing of daemon at any given moment
daemon could be honoring his brother's
decrees or spending time in brothels
with his closest confidant massaria a
woman who's made a life for herself
after being sold more times than she
could count matt smith goes back to the
coin analogy and says daemon is
constantly flipping sides in this way
whether that's siding with viserys or
his own interests
i don't think it's about ambition to the
throne and all that the actor clarifies
i think a lot of that is about his
brother
viserys doesn't even ride a dragon
anymore yet he was capable of mounting
balerio on the black dread the beast
that once bonded with aegon targaryen
the conqueror of westeros king viserys
understands the responsibility that
comes with commanding dragons and their
ability to destroy the realm says
considine who is 48 who wanted to bring
a tragic tone to the character now the
mantra we had for him was that he's a
good man a bad king because he just
wants to make everyone happy but also
viserys has an ego he's got a great
tragedy in his life but there is a part
of him that's going how am i going to be
remembered in hundreds of years they
don't remember peaceful kings they
remember warriors they remember tyrants
nobody alive in this story has ever seen
a war or a meaningful conflict condo
elaborates yes there have been
skirmishes and tournaments but we're
living in this society based on
conflicts for power we're watching a
moment in time where every man has been
trained for battle since birth but
battle doesn't always happen that build
up energy leaks out from the cracks and
starts to wear on itself where you
almost need the release of war in order
to keep the whole thing from boiling
over though the targaryens and their
dragons are in the title house of the
dragon is truly anchored by rhaenyra and
alicent who will first see in that
honeymoon glow of friendship before
their adult lives become consumed with
fire and blood they are central female
characters who were at once credited and
also blamed with the war allison grew up
in the red keep as the daughter of the
hand of the king otto hightower with
virtually no life outside of king's
landing she forms a fast and immediate
bond with rhaenyra
the actresses feel that alicent is
misunderstood based on how she's written
in fire and blood but that's by design
the novel is less of a literary
narrative and more of a historical
document written by archmaester gildane
who often describes events through those
who say to know what happened history as
viewers will come to find out rarely
gets any of these characters right
rhaenys targaryen's marriage to lord
corliss valerion reflects the deep bond
between their houses that goes back to
the conquering of westeros
the targaryens own the skies and the
valerians own the seas the ruler of
driftmark house velaryon's ancestral
seat inherits the name lord of the tides
and is often granted a seat among the
ruling targaryen kings small council the
most famous of all the valerians is lord
corliss nicknamed the sea snake after
his ship he's an explorer he's traversed
farther than any before him bringing
back riches that have made house
valerion one of the most wealthy
institutions in all of westeros now when
it comes to lord corliss velaryon actor
steve toussaint says no one wants to f
with him the targaryens have dragons but
still they don't want to lose the whole
ocean which he commands he knows he has
power and he knows that they need him
he's this fearless guy he's very rich
now and he likes everyone to see that he
is rich but as the actor i have to find
a way to humanize it steve toussaint
came to think of lord corliss more like
tywin lannister in part because he
auditioned for the role with lines of
charles dances game of thrones dialogue
but also because the actor saw the sea
snake as ruthlessly dedicated to his
family even if it doesn't always come
through in the smoothest of ways
the sea snake is a father and wants what
he thinks is best for his children the
actor says before clarifying that the
character is still much more at home on
the battlefield or at sea
it's much simpler then he says
if you don't do it right you die that's
it there's no gray area alright ladies
and gentlemen as you can see there is a
whole lot of information in the new
article released by entertainment weekly
i would highly recommend reading it for
yourself because i only scratched the
surface in this video there is a link
down below i would also recommend
watching their whole teaser video which
is also embedded inside of the article i
think it's fascinating stuff that gives
us a great idea of what we will see in
the first season of house of the dragon
as always let me know what all of you
think about this down below i'm always
interested in hearing what you have to
say i want to thank all of you for
watching the video i have a hell of a
lot more videos heading your way in the
following days have a great day everyone
i'll see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you